[Música]
buenas tardes agradezco el espacio que
me han brindado para hablarnos de algo
que quizás muchos de ustedes saben pero
que yo les voy a dar algunas noticias
nuevas algunas viejas e impactar y ver
la realidad que tenemos hoy en córdoba
el título de mi charla es la sangre nos
salva como obtenemos esa sangre porque
es importante porque es necesaria porque
es el motivo de hoy agradecer este
espacio para poder contarles a ustedes
un poquito de esta historia ustedes
saben que la sangre es vital importante
corre por nuestras venas por nuestras
arterias tiene la importancia de hacer
funcionar
valdés nuestros órganos todos nuestros
órganos es vital tiene la conexión
mágica entre la mamá y el bebé a través
del cordón umbilical fluye
no tengo noticias para darles no se
compra no se ve
no se fabrica la tienen ustedes y la
tengo yo que pasa hoy porque este afán
de buscar los espacios para
transmitirles un mensaje donar sangre es
dar vida donar sangre salva tres vidas
conéctate comparte esto quiere decir que
nosotros en los hospitales en las
instituciones tenemos sangre tenemos
para abastecer parte de nuestras
necesidades pero no todas quiero
contarles que para obtenerla es gracias
a ustedes que se acercan un banco y
donan donan sangre lo triste por ahí de
todo esto es que no lo hacen
voluntariamente muchas veces lo hacen
movidos por un llamado de auxilio de
algún familiar de algún pariente
eso se llama donante de reposición tiene
mi donación tiene un nombre y un
apellido
yo voy a reponer lo que alguien uso o lo
que alguien va potencialmente usar
debo decirles que los bancos de sangre
los hospitales como una colega de mía en
algún momento lo refirió es el corazón
de un hospital porque porque tengo la
vitalidad de brindar sangre a quien lo
necesite pero el tema es como lo logró
como lo obtengo algunas cifras por
decirlo así esa donación que me llega a
los bancos de sangre hoy por darles un
número de diez de ustedes que se acercan
dos de ustedes son voluntarios ocho de
ustedes van a responder a un llamado de
un amigo o para una enfermedad o por una
posible cirugía va a ir entre comillas
obligado
qué buscamos hoy
seguramente lo han escuchado en muchas
campañas publicitarias el donante seguro
voluntario altruista el tema es cómo
llegamos al donante voluntario y por qué
esa diferencia de esos dos modelos en la
reposición
mi sangre tiene un nombre un apellido
para ayudar a alguien o aquel que no
tiene nombre pero que me sirve
y dona porque el donante voluntario
tiene una particularidad crea el hábito
el hábito de donar entonces al crear el
hábito tienen claro recomendaciones
tienen claro cuidados
y qué nos pasa a nosotros en los bancos
de sangre por diferentes estudios por
diferentes analogías que tenemos con
estudios de sangre logramos entender que
el donante de reposición es bueno es
seguro pero tiene alta calidad
aquel donante que tiene en claro todos
los cuidados del momento de donar tengo
que contarles que en el 2017 un hospital
del cual te quiero mucho que todos
seguramente han escuchado nombrar que es
el hospital garraham los largos y los
largos cifras en las cuales compartimos
que necesitamos 2 millones de donantes
en argentinas para autoabastecernos en
el 2017 éramos 1.5 por ciento los que
dona vamos en números con respecto a la
población en general que era 45 millones
en ese momento donde vamos hay 170 mil
estamos lejos de los 2 millones
pero también debo decirles y con mucho
orgullo que el hospital garraham y
sustento regional logró este cambio de
paradigma
este cambio de modalidad de donar hoy el
hospital garraham no solicita donantes
llegan solos
se autoabastece llevo tiempo llevo
comunicarse con ustedes llevo socializar
la medicina al lado de la comunidad
hoy en córdoba estamos en ese camino
transitando el camino lento de llegar a
la donación voluntaria
el tema es que fácil ir a donar
es un feedback entre ustedes y nosotros
es brindarles el mensaje para que llegue
y ahí tenemos que jugar con la intención
con la motivación con la imaginación
llegar realmente al objetivo porque
nuestro nosotros está transmitir un
mensaje que los conecte con ustedes
cuanto lleva a donar un momentito de tu
vida te dirigida a cualquier banco acá
en córdoba la universidad banco
municipal banco en la provincia la
fundación banco central de sangre no
necesitan nombres necesitan acercarse y
donar es decir yo quiero ser donante
voluntario te van a recibir
te van a hacer una pequeña entrevista te
vas a pasar por un examen físico muy
cortito vas a ir a la sala de extracción
en la sala extracción cuánto dura la
duración de 5 a 7 minutos y que lo hago
yo después de eso
y esa sangre se va a procesar se va a
procesar en varios componentes porque
nosotros hablamos de donación de sangre
alguna vez escucharon salva tres vidas
porque salvó a tres vidas porque a raíz
de esa donación de esa bolsita que yo
logro en esos cinco o siete minutos yo
puedo fraccionar y procesar en otros
hemos componentes que tienen un objetivo
terapéutico
ya sea para enfermedades en las cuales
el soporte en otras es el tratamiento
primordial en el trasplante
yo soy referente del hospital garraham
de la donación de sangre de cordón esa
sangre de cordón también se dona en
donde en el momento del parto cesárea o
para alguien en particular que tiene una
enfermedad específica en pediatría o
bien en donación voluntaria y tengo la
suerte de participar de ese programa que
tiene impacto mundial entonces qué es
cuál es la idea buscar ese donante
voluntario seguro altruista este pequeño
instante que nos brindan para poderles
transmitir el mensaje espero que algo de
estas cifras algo de impacto porque la
idea es abastecer nos tener sangre que
no haya un nombre un apellido para la
sangre
que hay muchos hilos que dar ejemplos
por ejemplo en río cuarto está
trabajando un grupo de docentes en un
grupo que se llama donarme en el que
trabajar en la promoción de la donación
voluntaria y el trasplante de médula
ósea en salta los chicos de diseño
gráfico de nueva ciudad católica de
salta junto con las maternidades están
trabajando y trabajaron todo el año en
la promoción y en el impacto de la
donación voluntaria en los bancos de
sangre entonces participaron en colectas
en promociones en córdoba se hace lo
mismo quizás no se ve pero el trabajo es
lento y está en nosotros como equipo de
salud en pequeños momentos y en pequeños
espacios transmitirla a ustedes
acérquese a donar donar sangre y dar
vida
creamos puentes hoy yo te salva golfos
mañana me salva a mí
[Aplausos]
ah
[Música]